hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I
find myself alone in the ocean
I find myself wandering adrift choking
in the crushing depths and the cold
loneliness of the empty abyss below me
and he may be thinking to yourself oh no
ten seconds I'm about to run out of
oxygen but no I was actually smart about
this I got my save file and brought it
with me all the way back to Cincinnati
and therefore I know exactly what I'm
going to be doing in the future
hahaha I bet I scared you oh so I'm
going to be a bit more calm and quiet in
this one just because my voice is still
not 100% it wasn't it wasn't good to
immediately come back in recording and
start screaming in a horror game but
fortunately I have a plan so I've left
the safety of my other base and as you
can see my sub my seamoth is right here
but my seamoth has run out of power I'll
fix that in a second but I've got some
messages here that I'm going to read now
and then put them in a future Locker
when I make my new base on the edge of
the grand reef which is where I'm going
to be going next so first off you dang
said adjacent the kelp forest there
should be a large wreck in the grand
reef where you can find bioreactor
fragments also in the deep grand reef
you can find that gassy cruise last base
where you can find alien containment
chamber fragments which is what I'm
going to be looking for in the next
adventure down into the dark inactive
lava zone but unfortunately I thought I
could do that with the prawn suit but
Elite headhunter 4 says the prawn suit
right now is about as useful as a
sandpaper dildo which doesn't sound
pleasant in any capacity not that I have
a vast experience with dildos and then
the Crimson soldier says mark scanned
the glass hallways and parts of the base
that you don't got specs for which is
something that I have not been doing so
thank you for the recommendation and I
will be doing that when I get down to
the die when I get
under the de gosse's last base which is
a very interesting idea that they were
able to go deeper and deeper into the
ocean they went down to from the safety
of the island which I don't know why
they would have left the island to the
purplish area that was even deeper and
then down to the Grande roof which is
even deeper than they were once why did
they keep getting pushed deeper and
deeper into the ocean why didn't they
find safety up above the ocean or maybe
the topography changed the tides changed
maybe there was times when the ocean
rose and sank with the coming going of
the tides but why also did they not go
for the alien technology that was on the
other Island now it's not an illusion
that the technology wasn't there like
we've been playing in the game when they
add stuff this thing is really drifting
when they add stuff it's as if it was
always there anyway I fixed this thing
up by the way I fixed it and there have
been some messages
this is Avery Quinn of trading ship
Sunbeam Aurora do you read over no still
nothing
these old Terran ships they've run out
of engine grease they sent an SOS offer
to help they don't pick up Aurora I'm
out on the far side of the system it's
gonna take more than a week to reach
your position do you still need our
assistance over I'll try them again
tomorrow see what the long-range scan
picks up to the meantime yeah charters
gonna have us wasting our profit margin
running errands for all Tara
uh-huh okay so that's interesting that
means there's a rescue ship on the way
that's gonna take about a week to get
here depending on whether or not they
actually decide that were there worth
the trouble I don't have a means of
getting a signal out to them so the only
thing that I can hope to do is
deactivate
the alien gun before they arrived now I
don't know when exactly they're going to
be arriving but to get to that I need to
get down to the alien fragments down at
the de Gossie crew base now I have some
stuff with me I have a rotten Lander
troops and power cells these ion
crystals which are the same power as an
atomic bomb
no wait was it was it did it say it was
the the power of the Sun in the pocket
of my hand either way not pleasant for
me to hold around and probably
radioactive unless these aliens have
figured out a way to create energy
without extreme amounts of radioactivity
going on but either way not important to
me I have other plans
thanks Karen thanks for taking a nap on
me when I need to do the most so what we
have to do is we have to get down to the
base there and then build a base as
close as possible to the edge of the
reef and then we'll build a moon pool to
be able to build more whoo you guys are
big I still have to build a base on the
back of you someday I'm gonna do that
you're not gonna stop me from doing that
anyway we're gonna build a base as close
to the edge of the grand reef as we
possibly can and then take that down
into the depths and hopefully when we
build the moon pool nearby
and I've let my water and health go to
waste
but I'm not gonna worry about that
because I have the means with which to
do something about that oh my god I
frickin hate that yeah I don't think I
need to go down there but I think
there's gonna lead needed grand reef
hello okay hi that was weird
what the hell was this sounds yeah
either I'm hearing things that I've
never heard before or we are in
something new here there is an I know I
know that there's an entrance to the
inactive lava zone somewhere around here
so long as I can find a relatively
appropriate place for a base which might
be on the edge
holy [ __ ] that's a new sound okay I
apologize in advance if I scream like a
little girl because it's gonna it's
gonna peep the [ __ ] out of this
microphone right now and I know that's
not gonna be pleasant but I'm gonna try
to keep it relatively calm as I explore
the depths of this ocean I find its
infinite wonders a constant reminder of
how small I really am so what I need to
do is I need to build and quickly which
means I need to gather materials and
quickly because I don't have enough well
that's not what I need that's not gonna
help me at all
can I get some goddamn titanium do you
guys have not even have titanium I can't
build a base out of goddamn gold now can
i whoa hey buddies oh it's the sea
traders hey friends I doing down there
oh geez I got all the warnings going off
yeah I probably should have gathered
materials before I came out here but
then again I'm dumb I'm gonna go do that
yeah I know we'll save that food block
for a little later so what I'm under do
is I'm gonna be back right quick and I'm
gonna go gather some materials because
I'm gonna need them to be able to build
this thing because I do not have enough
I know that for a fact if I had my pron
sued with the right attachment maybe I
would have a chance but I don't man but
ever what what is that
oh cool
I need that it's the power cell charger
fragment which means then I'm gonna be
able to actually charge my power cells
which is awfully useful oh my god
I have never seen this area before so I
honestly don't know what to expect out
of it but I'm gonna check the check the
deposits real quick I get it
titanium yes okay so this is what I need
oh yeah yeah I don't have my rebreather
oh I never wear okay I know I know I
know I know I know
titanium oh my god is so tiny they're
tiny oh hello hello oh I'm like a child
where is my goddamn Seema where's was
y'all God are you hold still for just
one second before you start drifting off
again maybe now that I repaired it I can
just pilot it again we just picked up a
massive debris field at your location
yeah I didn't know how bad how many of I
didn't know we're now on route to your
location we're gonna bring you home
Sunmi about what else guys say or a
six-seater we are need to slightly equip
the analyst has attempted a planet
landing in the Academy simulator holds a
bad situation but so far all the
alternatives uh-huh thanks for keeping
it positive for us do you appreciate all
the you know wonderful news that you're
bringing along and welcome back
everybody I know I went on a little bit
of a misadventure there but I realized
that I needed to shift gears in exactly
what I was doing see I've got a lot of
ambition here but I don't have
absolutely everything I need and there's
one place that I have not gone yet then
again there are many places that I have
yet to go but there's one place that has
just a hint of danger that I need to go
to where there's a lot of resources and
scannable that I need to find and they
exist
in both the floating island zone and the
dunes and the sand dunes are
particularly dangerous because I know
there's a great many Reaper leviathans
and I've been told that there may even
be more Reaper leviathans than I had
previously encountered and I need to
make a quick pit stop because I need
some table Quirrell for a computer chip
that I'm gonna need whenever I make my
second base and I'll do that in a bit
but I just moved it to pieces for that
so the rest of this it's just an
opportunity for me to go out into the
great beyond with which I have not yet
explored and see what lies in the
darkness for me because I know there are
wrecks oh I know there's a great many
wrecks and there are new things that
have been added that I've yet to see and
I will find them whoo that's that's a
bad sound is that a scannable or is that
just an exploded piece excuse you I hope
you broke a tooth don't try it again
buddy you lose it is but I already have
that damn it's alright okay
I see you oh I see you oh I see you so
you had a lot of things and um oh [ __ ]
stop doing that geez you did a lot of
things so this was a this would have
been a good place to go for the mobile
vehicle Bay and a rescue Billy Samwise
oh no Billy Jeffrey sim why's it
Marshall I'm sorry sons it's just that I
don't care oh boy okay we good oh well
you're a little far off from where
you're supposed to be oh my god are you
maybe I'm farms
hmm nope you're exactly where you need
to be aren't you cuz you're right by the
floater sorry you're right by the
floating islands and upon the floating
islands bridged across the back of two
of you I know for a fact is another
wreck and I have a funny feeling I'm
staring at it right in the face oh yes I
am
hello hello friend you're gonna tell me
exactly what I need to know you're gonna
show me exactly how I make what I need
to make is that a bit of a propulsion
Canon hell yes please thank you got that
Hey hell yeah yeah bad that was quick
in and out ow goddammit stop bashing me
I mean I know that was probably my fault
but I don't have insurance so I can't
make it claim to that lets fix me back
up a bit
oh those are those are bad sounds oh
that sounds terrible okay alright then
yeesh so there's a lot of areas like
this that I have not yet explored and I
will very soon I'm just gonna go in and
see a chunk
I've never even opened a door like this
well [ __ ]
erosion patterns on the landmasses
suspended here suggest they once floated
on the surface floated on the surface
you mean what is that stays this rifle
hell yes so these floating islands were
once like the giant floating island in
that they were a floating island but now
they're just kind of sinking a little
bit because the the girthy bubble balls
seemed to be running out of you know
juice come on you better hurry I'm
running out of air here
oh geez come on
come on come on come on better be
something good behind this whoo what is
that whoo
don't climb on or get off this equipment
pron wait there's something for the
prawn in here I gotta go I gotta go
gotta go gotta go gotta go gotta go
gotta go gotta go gotta go
and pitstop yes I feel much better now
but there's something for the prawn in
here so I got to find out exactly what's
going on here there's another stasis
rifle piece but if there's a piece for
the prawn to get its grappling on I am
going to take that prawn everywhere with
me
oh it's a promise sir that's not gonna
help me I thought my inventory would
have been full was that I already have
the propulsion cannon did I get the
stasis rifle probably prawn suit
fragment whoa grappling arm that sounds
good [ __ ] only half of it up there's the
other half okay but I thought I thought
it already came with the grappling arm
oh now this is a pickle grappling arm
stasis rifle damn it this one probably
doesn't have what I need I need to get
out of here I need to go go go go go you
could just stop screaming at me I've got
enough to deal with right now stop
banging if you're banging on my seem off
it does not want any SAAP [ __ ] all
right yeah this just leads to the prawn
room what is this got no signal there no
signal there whole lot of nothing Nitori
full yeah there's nothing here for me it
doesn't have the drill bit arm which is
what I need yeah just the grappling arm
and I've already got plenty of that so I
just need to get out of here you she she
she she she I know I know I know I know
I know I know I know
stop banging on the seamoth stop it
all right so that answers my question
and that that answers where I need to go
next which is an even more dangerous
place and I've already been to good God
here comes the mushroom forest which I
believe probably has another piece of
technology that I don't yet possess but
oh oh I know where I am
oh I know exactly where I am
oh I know exactly where I am I'm at the
I'm at the mouth of the Beast
I'm at the uh I'm at the entrance of the
inactive lava zone aren't I
oh that seems bad and dark and bad and
dark yoosh but I know there is a large
wreckage around here somewhere yeah I
don't like it when whole areas don't
load because that's how these things
creep up on me oh no oh no no no no no
no no no no no Nana Nana Nana
oh I see you I see you friend I see you
detecting multiple Leviathan class
life-forms in the region are you certain
whatever you're doing is worth it yeah
I'm not so sure about that myself Karin
is what I told you guys about this being
an incredibly dangerous area to just
flutter around in because there are a
lot of leviathans here I - and for good
reason
it does guard the entrance to this place
where apparently the story continues I
see some littered bits up there it is
okay good good thing I've got some water
on me I do not have water on me why do I
not have water on me I thought I had
water on me why do I not have water on
me this is [ __ ] okay so this is now
turned into a race against time okay I
can't go any farther down I'm willing to
bet that there are
some pieces down here that I need so I
need to go now you don't like this I
don't like this at all there's got to be
pieces in here that I need cuz it's got
to be consistent open yes I can open up
open up please tell me there's something
in here that's good
oh thermal plant well I guess that is
good it's not exactly what I was looking
for but okay I'll take it
[ __ ] there's another one good good good
good good good good good good good not
that not that is all full up I've
already had the thermal fragment
reinforced dive suit I guess that's good
okay good good good good good I'm
running out of time [ __ ] cuz not only am
i running out of oxygen right now but
I'm also running out of course yep yep
I'm also running out of water and I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to get
back with a limited amount of water that
I have I should I got I got maybe one
more try I gotta go one more down one
more dive and I gotta find eating this
next batch I got to find like a back
entrance I think there's another hole in
there that's kind of like the other one
that I went into I just got to make sure
that I don't crash and I hope for the
best
let's do this yeast that's not a good
sign please do not eat me yeah here we
go okay
don't even bother dude don't even bother
what is that vehicle off great console
that sounds good okay there's one of
them [ __ ] I do not have time to cut down
this full damn door
cuz I gotta get back alive because I've
got a lot of things in my inventory that
I don't think I've saved yet yeah
I thought I had water I felt I had tons
of water yes yes yes not that not that
get the [ __ ] out of my face get are you
[ __ ] kidding me go [ __ ] go I can
do this I can do this I can do this I
can do this I can do this I can do this
I can do this I can do this I can do
this I can do this I can do this I'm out
I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out
how to out doubt doubt doubt doubt doubt
doubt doubt doubt doubt doubt doubt out
let me out are you [ __ ] kidding me
let me out are you kidding me let me out
Jesus boy I made it so I got a book it
back to the safe shallows and get some
water immediately because I do not have
any but I got a thermal plant generator
I got the drill bit for the arm I've got
everything that I needed so I should be
okay unless I yes I have a hibbity
hibbity hibbity hibbity hibbity gonna
make you're gonna make it I'm gonna make
it guys guys I'm gonna make it it's
gonna happen whoo boy
oh boy whoo boy oh right down to the
wire I also don't know why the life pot
is so laggy cuz lately the life pot has
been just unbelievably laggy like this
is the frame rate that I'm getting out
of this okay
can you Wow can you not oh my god
subject 1 1 7 8 3 destroyed notes which
patrol has every mean what oh jeez why
is it so laggy here we did what we set
out to accomplish we've got the drill
bit we can get the prong suit down into
the deep areas we can actually mine
enough resources to be able to build a
base very quickly down there and then we
should be able to do exactly what we
need to do with just a little
preparation I'll be able to get a base
down and do the deep depths of the grand
reef and then create a base to go see
the last base of the de Gossie get the
alien fragments and then go down and
in active lava zone and see what the
hell is up down there so either way I
know Karen thank you I love you thanks
for taking care of me and thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye